oh my god and we do it look like your
neck is completely broken like it oh my
god please don't you Timmy
no no no no is that just a mirror behind
you oh oh God we are such a
dysfunctional family
I hate PewDiePie because PD by sucks and
Heath and sucks fanboys sucks
PewDiePie sucks don't call me fat called
you fat too [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you
oh my god that laugh wait I can do that
better it are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
hey what do you want what do you want
from me Daffy Duck didn't flinch oh my
god that that is adorable
ha ha can I just do this instead instead
of all these [ __ ] horror games ah
here we are
ok so this is my face this is my face
and a baby oh my god again
[ __ ]